[Narrator] Here's the answer: we can define a procedure named replace spy.
It takes 1 parameter as its input.
I'll call the parameter P.
We could call it spy and that might be a more natural name for it here,
but to avoid confusion with the variable spy, we're using in the example, I'll call it P.
For the body of replace spy what we want to do is change the value
in position 2 of the value past it.
So, we can do that within an assignment statement.
On the left side we're selecting the cell, and we're replacing it
with a value that we get from the old value in that position plus 1.
This has the behavior that we want, and to have a better understanding why
let's see what happens when we pass a value to our procedure.
Here's what we had before the call.
We've initialized the variable spy to hold the list
containing 3 elements that are numbers 0, 0, 7.
Then we make the call to replace spy, passing in spy.
What happens when we call a procedure the name of the variable in the procedure
now refers to the object that's passed in.
So, now the value of P of the parameter here refers to that object.
Then we do the assignment.
We replace the value in position 2 of P with it's previous value plus 1,
so that changes this value to 8.
The parameter P and the variable spy both refer to the same object,
so that also changes the value of spy.
Not that there's no return statement here.
We don't need to return a new value.
We've modified the value of the list that was passed in,
and I want to emphasize that this is different from what's happened in other procedures.
If you remember in an earlier exercise you defined the procedure INC.
It takes 1 input, we'll call it N, and it adds 1 to that.
If we remove the return statement from INC,
it doesn't change the value that's passed in.
It does nothing, and here's why:
suppose we had code like this, we'll introduce a variable A,
give it the value 3; we'll call INC on A.
What happens here--well, the variable A that name refers to the value 3.
When we passed that to INC--well, the same thing happens
as happened when we passed the mutable list as parameter P to replace spy.
The name N now refers to the same value as A referred to,
but we can't mutate that value.
What happens inside INC is an assignment statement.
We assign to N the value N +1,
so that the changes the value N refers to.
Now N refers to a value 4, but that doesn't change the value A refers to.
A still has the value 3.
So, we can see with numbers we can't mutate the value of a number.
If we could everywhere the value 3 existed before--well, now it would mean 4.
That would be pretty confusing.